steven guilbeault ministre fédéral de
l'environnement est avec nous en direct
monsieur guilbeault bonsoir bonsoir
c'est la victoire de la politique de la
terre brûlée a dit un de vos anciens
collègues responsables d'un groupe
écologique l'opposition dit est ce qu on
avait vraiment besoin d'un milliard de
nouveaux baril de pétrole d'ici 30 ans
canada sur guilbaud êtes vous à l'aise
vraiment avec cette décision la
triste condition qu'ils étaient
évidemment très difficile comme on en
prendrait lance souvent dans lorsqu'en
gouverne le pays de 37 millions de
personnes souhaitant nous avons nous
sommes engagées lorsque nous avons
réformé processus d'évaluation
environnementale de l'inde est politisé
et j'écoutais les membres de votre panel
dire qu'il fallait être dépolitisé un
peu ces choses là bas c'est exactement
ce que nous avons fait avec l'évaluation
environnementale et leur chien un groupe
d'experts qui étudie le projet pendant
quatre ans et qui me fait une
recommandation en disant ben nous on
estime que le projet n'a pas d'impact
significatif
souhaitant le promoteur 137 conditions
qui doit respecter deux conditions qui
nous et qu'il n'a jamais été imposée au
canada aucun projet c'est à dire que le
projet soit 9,0 carboneutre si d'ici
2050 ça me fait penser vous allez
sursauter mais dans notre homme qui
disait on peut faire du charbon clean
l'adus charbon propre ça me fait penser
à ce que vous êtes en train de dire
qu'un milliard de baril de pétrole de
plus de plus de ce qu'on fait finalement
c'est un projet versé un milliard de
baril de pétrole de plus monsieur
guilbeault sais pas du tout ce que je
dis pas que c'est un projet vert
ce que ce que même le giec est l'argent
le giec cette semaine dans son rapport
dick on va quand même consommé 36 à peu
près 35 36 millions de barils de pétrole
par jour en 2005 ans dans un monde
carboneutre donc ça va diminuer
énormément on va passer de 100 millions
à 35 l'agencé de l'énergie dit même 25
millions d'arrivées trois par jour vous
savez je n'ai jamais eu de voiture je
n'aurais probablement jamais et quand je
prends le train pour venir à savoir ce
train là fonctionnent au pétrole et
j'aimerais vous dire patrice que on va
se débarrasser de notre dépendance au
pétrole au cours des prochaines années
même au québec vous êtes un milliard de
baril pétrole par jour saviez-vous ça
correspond à combien de temps de
consommation de pétrole juste pour le
québec un nouveau une idée c'est certain
ou un certain je le dire d'entrée de jeu
alors c'est sûr que ça paraît beaucoup
c'est un très grand chef mais nous
consommons beaucoup de pétrole à
l'échelle planétaire il faut réduire sa
et le plan que nous avons déposé la
semaine dernière qui a été encensé par
la plupart des experts même écologie
sont c'est un plan très solide ce plan
repose sur des données de nos
régulateurs indépendants qui la régie de
l'énergie du canada qui prévoit une
augmentation pétrole d'à peu près un
million d'ici 2030 allons nous on avait
des gens était 10h dans le plan qu'on a
déposé la semaine prochaine est ce que
nous nous sommes engagés à faire c'est
d'éliminer progressivement les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre de tourisme mais
monsieur limoges je comprends ça mais
vous auriez pu politiquement comme
gouvernement dire non
ne rien pu lui dire non
c'est certaine c'est certain qu'on
aurait pu dire non effectivement envoyé
un message qu'on a vu en accroître la
capacité pétrolière du canada encore
plus
si on aurait fait son honoraires
politiser un processus qu'on a cherché à
dépolitiser au cours des dernières
années c'est sûr que si on décide de
faire ce qu'ont confié à des experts le
soin de faire l'évaluation de projets
comme ça il faut prendre le risque après
il faut vivre avec les recommandations
de ces jeunes si on fait comme les
conservateurs à l'époque et tout est
politique d'alors n'a pas besoin de
faire ça et je vous signalerais quand
même que ce même groupe d'experts là sur
l'évaluation environnementale dans
certains projets nous a dit non il ya
trop de lait trop d'impact le projet
laurentienne dans le port de québec
l'agent ce projet leur art est trop des
pins là vous me parlez oui mais mais
pour que les gens comprennent ce que
vous me parlez de l'impact
environnemental
du projet de la plateforme des 30 puis
et c'est sûr que ça soit mieux fait par
une compagnie du danois qui vient bravo
aux tant mieux j'évoque la question qui
est posée et qui se posait au cabinet
fédéral je présume c est ce que compte
tenu de ce carré contenu du giec compte
tenu de ce qu'on dit depuis des années
est ce qu'on a à voir vraiment comme
message à la planète que nous on va
accroître notre production est très bien
je vous dis pas de couper les robinets
partout bien sûr que non que le pétrole
va encore être utilisé pendant des
années mais d'accroître encore comme
symbole politique cévennes guilbaud
pour vous j'imagine ça lui a dû ravaler
vraiment
c'est certainement très difficile mais
il faut être conscient de la réalité
nous allons continuer consommer du
pétrole pendant de nombreuses décennies
et même jusqu'en 2050 oui mais pas
besoin de la croix glorieuse il vaut à
ce point là et dans ce cas la patrie
c'est ce qu'on veut consommer du pétrole
qui me dit fois plus de gaz à effet de
serre par barry que celui de baie du
nord c'est le code 2d sans diminuer vous
avez peut-être vu aujourd'hui sur le
site web du ministère de l'environnement
du canada que il ya un projet de sables
bitumineux qui n'ira pas de l'avant 3
millions 2,3 millions de tonnes de co2
par année parce que ça c'est 250 mille
tonnes pour le projet et du nord c'est
vraiment dix fois plus dans un monde où
on veut qu'on se continuer à consommer
du pétrole de moins en moins il faut
consommer il faut aller vers le pétrole
qui a le moins d'impact sur sur les gaz
à effet de serre et le projet b du nord
et le ti projet oui mais vous c'est vous
partez du principe qu'il fallait qu'on
était obligé collectivement
d'accroître notre production de pétrole
à ce point là or on peut refuser projet
très polluants en alberta et refuser un
projet moins polluants au large de
terre-neuve où si on peut faire les
mêmes deux choses je pars du principe
que je pars pas du principe qu'il
fallait dire oui ou non un ou l'autre je
pars du principe que dans la mesure où
nous allons continuer en tant que
société en consommer pendant longtemps
aussi bien consommé le pétrole que le
moins d'impact sur l'environnement et
qui en plus je devrais carboneutre
seven ou bien vous aussi est ce que
c'est la pige je respecte ça la
solidarité ministérielle puis vous vous
êtes je vais peut-être faire des gains
ailleurs mais est-ce que vous avez songé
à démissionner non pas du tout
c'est un projet symbolique je peux
comprendre pour pour plusieurs mais pour
la première fois dans l'histoire du pays
nous avons un plan de lutte aux
changements climatiques qui montre
comment nous allons atteindre nos
objectifs il ya trouvé moins d'attrait
son pays dans le monde producteur de
pétrole en plus qu'ils devront remettre
un plafond sur les émissions secteur et
du gaz
et c'est ce que nous sommes en train de
faire trouvez moi un pays qui est un
objectif de réduction de la pollution de
méthane un gaz à effet de serre très
puissants de 75% d'ici 2030 on est en
voie d'atteindre 45 % donc presque
moitié moins de méthane dans le secteur
du pétrole et du gaz mettant le kiki 28
fois plus puissant que le co2 interne
son potentiel de résultats
75% le grade il n'y aura aucun autre
pays au monde encore moins pays
producteurs de pétrole qui ont mis en
place des mesures comme seul homme nous
sommes très ambitieux ni nous allons
errance continuité du pétrole très bien
mais reconnaissait avec moi steven
guilbeault et je vais vous laisser là
dessus
que le symbole que ça renvoyait
politique
de dire non à un nouveau projet de cette
ampleur encore une fois on parle d'un
gros projet aura été autant de salles
et évidemment s'arrêter je peux
comprendre que pour certains c'est un
symbole important mais on doit gouverner
pour l'ensemble de la population pour
l'ensemble des intérêts de la population
inclut bien entendu là la question
environnementale et je pense que c'est
ce que nous cherchons un faible en tout
cas c'est pas votre meilleur si vous
avez à choisir votre manière journée ça
ne sera pas aujourd'hui on s'entend
je remercie pas plus sévères gilbert
binette fédéral de l'environnement de
changement climatique nous a parlé en
direct d'ottawa merci à monsieur
guilbeault bien sûr vent